an altercation at one of the doorways
into the main terminal building at Hong
Kong's
Airport anti-government demonstrators
incensed that access is being denied and
blocked by security guards but
everything has changed here all the
entrances and exits to and from the
terminal and our manned by security no
ticket no obvious reason to be here than
no access police - now patrol the
departure concourse the airport has a
temporary injunction stopping the sit-in
and the closure of the airport which
brought delays cancellations and
ultimately chaos it meant that the
protesters numbers dwindled to a few
dozen sitting together in solidarity for
a cause that has been damaged by events
in the airport the mob mentality that
led to two men being beaten up cable
tied and abused for hours has shot
people in Hong Kong the attempts by the
police to get the men out ended in
pandemonium in and around determine the
police here are clearly fears the Hong
Kong police have always facilitate
peaceful and orderly protests over the
years but the extremely radical and
violent acts have certainly crossed deny
and not to be most severely condemned
this sit-in that started last Friday and
often reached thousands of people has
always been controversial and
potentially divisive some of the
travelers heading home say they believe
there could be dire consequences some
soldiers come come here and take over a
Hong Kong they think that might happen
poopies happens
you cannot solve this problem I think
words come to worse would be like that
so Chinese army on the streets for Hong
Kong and that's the end of Hong Kong as
we know
getting serious yeah the Hong Kong and
Beijing governments have condemned
what's happened at the airport but the
protest movement is still there separate
to these events it's fair to say that a
lot of people in Hong Kong was shocked
by the events at the airport and
certainly they're shocked by the fact
that two men were bound and beaten over
a long period of time the point to
remember though is that the protest
movement as a whole still has huge
support here
the numbers may be down in the airport
but across Hong Kong people are likely
to turn out at any future demonstrations
once again it's already started at
police station 30 minutes from the
airport targeted by demonstrators tear
gas fired this isn't a big one but it's
clear this crisis just isn't even near
reaching an end there's more to come
Gerard Sky News Hong Kong